Narrator:
Tonight, Christmas comes early
on "Shark Tank."
Ho, ho, ho!
The holiday season
is stressful.
Ugh!
This is a UFB ‐‐
un‐frickin'‐believable.
[ Laughter ]
Just when I think
I've seen it all.
I'm hair‐challenged.
That's the problem.
Hey.
It's a Christmas miracle!
‐What?!
I guess it's time.
Does anyone have
a burning question?
No!
‐Whoa!
‐Ooh!
♪♪
Narrator: First in the Tank
is an easier way
to decorate for the holidays.
♪♪
[ Chuckles ]
Hi, Sharks.
I'm Christmas Kurt,
chief artificial
Christmas tree farmer
at Easy Treezy,
the world's easiest
Christmas tree.
Now, I know it's Christmas,
but where are all
the decorations for the Tank?
Mark, did you forget
to put up the tree again?
Always.
[ Chuckles ]
Maybe all we need
is a little Christmas magic.
Does anybody know any elves?
[ Cheering, laughter ]
Oh, there they are ‐‐
the Easy Treezy elves!
I bet they can help!
Let's turn this tank
into a holiday masterpiece!
[ Cheering, laughter continue ]
♪♪
Easy Treezy was invented
to solve the headaches
of putting up
an artificial Christmas tree.
Our trees are extremely light
and go up extremely quickly
all by yourself.
Our memory‐wire patent‐pending
cone technology
features an industry‐first
electromagnetic lighting system,
securely snaps together
and instantly
illuminates the lights.
Wow.
Now, let's talk decorating.
We have a designer collection
that ships
completely decorated
right out of the box,
all the ornaments attached.
Sets up in under a minute
and you are done
with your Christmas tree.
Love to decorate
with those cherished ornaments
you've collected
over a lifetime?
No problem.
Easy Treezy
has a natural collection
that allows you to decorate
the trees any way you like.
And what's best is,
once you attach the ornaments,
you can actually
store them attached
so that next year,
they're ready to go.
‐Wow.
Now, what's the worst part
about the holidays?
When they're over!
[ Laughter ]
And we have to take
everything down.
Lucky for us,
with Easy Treezy,
it goes down
as fast as it went up
and conveniently stores,
hung in closets, under beds,
or laid on shelves,
thanks to
our lay‐flat technology.
Wow.
Now our Tank looks like
a cozy holiday home,
and I haven't even
had enough time
to tell you
how much money I want!
[ Laughter ]
So, about that...
[ Cheering, laughter ]
I'm looking for $400,000
for 10% of my company
to help put an Easy Treezy
in every living room
across America.
Now, we put out
some hot cocoa for you.
It's a special cocoa
to help loosen up your wallets.
[ Laughter ]
What does this tree
sell for right there?
This one will sell
for $779.
A tree like this
that's undecorated
will be our lower price point,
at $599, and then ‐‐
Barbara, you had an investment
in this space.
Yes.
Is that a lot
for a tree?
Well,
the modern Christmas tree ‐‐
that's been selling
so well, really,
so that's a good report card
for you.
They sell
for roughly $600 to $800.
Vastly different, opposite,
very modern.
These are traditional.
It's a different customer base,
I'm sure.
It is.
Well, the value here
is the simplicity, right?
The fact that it takes no time
to set it up,
takes no time
to tear it down.
The question is,
where can I buy it
at 10:00 p. m.
on Christmas Eve?
Well, so,
we're in big‐box retail.
We are in a store
called At Home.
It's 210 locations
across the U. S.
So, getting back
to the price point,
our trees in At Home are
actually retailing for $299.
Smaller tree?
Smaller?
Same‐size tree,
but different quality of tips,
different quantity
of lights.
What we can do here,
and we've started to work
with other big‐box retailers on,
is we can take a price point
people want to hit
and we can engineer a tree
to fit that price point.
You can customize it.
But the reason ‐‐
What are your margins
on that at $299?
So, we have about a 35% margin
to them right now.
We will drive that margin up
slightly with volume.
Kurt,
tell us about yourself.
I got to know
how you came up with this.
I'm from Wisconsin originally ‐‐
very rural town,
so we had forests
right behind our house,
and when Christmas came,
we'd go out
and chop down a Christmas tree.
And, you know, I always loved
the Christmas holiday.
It was very important to me ‐‐
a lot from my mom.
She ended up getting
a disease called scleroderma
when I was in high school,
and I got to watch her,
unfortunately,
kind of deteriorate,
and she eventually
passed away in 2009.
Sorry.
So, you know, the holidays
were so special to her,
that she couldn't any longer
go out and cut down
that Christmas tree
and haul it in
and do the whole live thing.
So, one of the things was,
how do I make a Christmas tree
that a single person
can put up?
Because regular Christmas trees
are very, very heavy.
This was always in my head, is,
"How do I fix this problem?"
Hmm.
Tell us about
your sales.
2018, we did $605,000.
This year, we're projected
to do $2.2 million.
Wow!
So, if you're only selling
in the 210 stores for $299 each,
what percentage
of your sales are there
and what other platforms
are you selling on?
That percentage of business
is about 15% of our business.
Just 15%?
The retail, yes.
We do a big business
through Amazon.
As everyone knows,
it's kind of the beast.
And then we do have
a great direct‐to‐consumer
through our own website.
What percentage is
direct‐to‐consumer?
About 50%.
Okay, so, how much money
have you raised,
how much have you put in
yourself...
A lot.
...and how much debt
do you have?
[ Laughter ]
No debt,
but I'm all‐in, man!
I'm all‐in!
Sure sounds like it.
So, you've raised
no outside money?
I haven't raised
any money.
How much have you put in?
About $500,000.
Corcoran: That's hard money
to put into any business.
I know.
Cuban: [ Laughs ]
It's meaningful.
I tell my sister,
"Sometimes I feel like
I'm at the casino table
on blackjack
and the dealer's
showing the 6
and you've got the 11
here...
And you got to double down,
right?
I got my shoes on the table,
the watch is out there.
Everything's there!
O'Leary: All right.
Let me push a couple of buttons
here on price.
I'm in this space
with a deal called GeekMyTree.
Yeah.
We provided the lighting
for a lot of manufacturers.
Yes.
And I learned
all the price points.
Yes.
Selling a tree for over $200
is really hard.
Yes.
Really?
So, I'm assuming
these $600 trees
that you're selling,
premium market,
direct‐to‐customer...
Yes.
No retailer's
gonna touch that.
No.
So, how is it that you think
you can get to $2.2 million?
But that's the whole purpose
of the design, right?
Kurt: So, last year,
it was really data collection.
So we learned what the customer
is, who the customer is,
how they interact
with the website.
Were you doing Facebook ads,
Instagram ads?
We tested Instagram.
Instagram and Facebook
were okay,
Google performed
the best.
Cuban: So, how much
are you gonna spend
on digital advertising
for this season?
We have budgeted
about $120,000.
‐That's it?
‐That's it.
Look, I want to tell you
something.
I'm actually
related to Scrooge.
He's my uncle.
And I tell you
what's gonna happen here.
You are going to be
very disappointed
in how few you sell
at that price above $299.
Nobody is going to pay you $700
for this tree.
It's not gonna happen.
I hate this business.
I'm out.
[ Laughs ]
Thank you, Kevin.
But other than that, Scrooge,
how was Christmas?
What a grumpy guy.
Kurt, who does
your digital advertising
for you right now?
We have a contractor
that does it down out of ‐‐
Okay.
To me,
that's the problem.
Your whole business is dependent
on your best skill
being your digital advertising
abilities.
Well, if I can ‐‐
so, we presented this tree
to Home Depot in early 2018.
We were actually invited
to their PLR in China.
They gave us a verbal commitment
for 70,000 units,
which came in right around,
like, $8.5 million.
You didn't think
it was relevant to tell us?
I was getting there.
I've had a lot of questions!
So, we had
the verbal commitment.
So, what happened is,
at that point, you know,
the mold was very expensive
to make.
What we presented to them
was actually, like,
a handmade sample
because we were still trying
to get that developed.
Right. Sure.
So, they look at that,
and then they don't have
the confidence
that we can ship 70,000 units.
But now I have data
that I can go back to Walmart,
Lowe's, Home Depot ‐‐
Okay, but still, Kurt,
what I'm saying is
the most profitable part
and the greatest upside
of your business
is what you sell
direct‐to‐consumer.
The key
to being successful there
is being
a great digital marketer.
I didn't get
a sense of confidence
that you really have that
under control.
So for those reasons,
I'm out.
♪♪
You know, I'm curious
about a couple of things.
You mentioned that you had
a problem with Home Depot.
Did you go back to that store
and resell them again
after you solved
the problem?
We've been in contact
with them throughout.
We still stay in touch
and give them updates.
Sounds like a relative
you don't really want to see.
[ Chuckles ]
No, we want to see them.
We want to see them
when we're right.
But still,
this is what's bothering me.
You had an $8 million order
that you let lie there a while.
We'll get them back.
Don't worry.
$8 million.
I pay a lot of attention
to $8 million.
I'm out.
Listen, your price point
is too high.
I don't think
it's the right deal for me,
so I'm sorry ‐‐
I'm out.
♪♪
Okay, then.
Robert, what are you gonna do?
Kurt, I love
the, uh, business.
Aesthetically,
I think it's beautiful.
And I love the reason
you started the company,
because I think it has a deeply
personal meaning to you.
But, to me, this business
is worth about $1 million.
Really?
For me to give you
$400,000,
I would need to own
40% of it.
[ Sighs ]
I don't think you,
with your shiny hat,
are going to
entertain that.
I mean, a million‐dollar
valuation is...
It's a gamble.
You are in a very high ‐‐
Is that an official offer,
by the way?
♪♪
Narrator:
Four Sharks are out.
Robert is Kurt's last chance
of getting a deal
for his artificial
Christmas tree company,
Easy Treezy.
To me, this business
is worth about $1 million.
Really?
For me to give you
$400,000,
I would need to own
40% of it.
It's a gamble. It's a gamble.
You are in a very high ‐‐
Is that an official offer,
by the way?
♪♪
I mean, if you're willing
to entertain that offer,
I'm certainly willing
to make it.
Wow.
$400,000 for 40%.
So, I mean, you know,
I understand the risk
that you're facing.
Certainly, everything in life
is unpredictable,
except for death and taxes.
Would you be at all flexible
to come down on the percentage
to, say, you know,
20% for $400,000?
I mean, that's giving me
a $2 million valuation.
Kurt, I think
you're learning a lot,
and I think
Mark made the point.
I wish you had more
digital marketing expertise.
But you're learning that.
You'll get there.
No one's born great
at something.
You learn it
along the way.
Well, you know,
it's better to hire experts
than to do everything yourself,
you know?
We want to make sure that we get
the absolute best person to ‐‐
Not always true.
When you start a business,
you got to be an expert
at what makes your business
grow and sell.
But the reality
of the situation is,
I am the only Shark
that's left.
I know.
♪♪
Kurt,
what are you gonna do?
♪♪
Do what's right
for you.
♪♪
I would be willing
to do the deal at 25%.
♪♪
I wouldn't.
It's how I see the deal
and how I equate it
and baked in the risk.
$400,000 for 40%.
♪♪
Yeah, I don't ‐‐
I can't accept that offer.
Cuban: Good for you
for sticking to your guns.
My best offer is 25%.
Yeah, you don't have to give
everything away.
I can respect that.
I still hate you.
But I can respect that.
[ Laughter ]
‐Congratulations, Kurt.
‐Listen. Good luck.
It's a nice tree.
It's a clever idea.
Thank you all.
Take care.
Merry Christmas.
Greiner: Bye. Good luck.
I wish we would've
landed a deal,
but, you know, life goes on,
and Easy Treezy will evolve
and live and, again,
will be in every house
in America at some point.
I thought
it was pretty.
You have to like
a skinny tree.
Oh, my God, Robert!
♪♪
[ Laughs ]
Run! Run, Robert!
You break it,
you buy it, Robert.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
Narrator:
Last season, Barbara Corcoran
made a deal with Mitch Allen
for his Santa staffing business,
HireSanta.
Allen: From Santa and all
the elves at the North Pole,
HireSanta would love to do
a deal with you, Barbara.
Corcoran: You got it.
Narrator: Let's see
how HireSanta is doing now.
Corcoran: Come on, Santas!
We don't want to be late!
Allen: Today,
I'm in the heart of Manhattan
on a very jolly mission.
Bloomingdale's has decided
to use HireSanta
to staff their flagship store
on days that Santa
can't be here himself.
Okay, Santas, Mitch and I
have some business to do.
Mrs. Claus, don't you dare
let these boys be naughty.
Santas: Ho, ho, ho!
Allen: We'll be
finalizing the deal today,
as well as holding
some Santa auditions.
The holidays
are such a big deal
at Bloomingdale's,
especially here.
Corcoran: HireSanta's business
is dependent
on hiring the right people
to play Santa Claus,
and I'm taking these auditions
very seriously.
I want perfect Santa Clauses.
Allen: Santa will try
his very best to be here,
but in case he's not,
we'll have some of Santa's
friends to take his place.
Okay, Santa, give us
your best "Ho, ho, ho."
‐Ho!
‐Merry...
‐Christmas!
Allen:
When I pitched HireSanta,
sales for 2017 were $331,000.
After making a deal
on "Shark Tank,"
our sales in 2018
were $1.4 million.
What's your favorite
Christmas movie?
We used Barbara's investment
to hire people specifically
for sales and marketing.
As head elf,
this has freed me up
to focus on big‐picture growth.
Now I'm closing deals
with great partners,
like Great Wolf Lodge
and T‐Mobile.
Santa, you've got the job.
‐Wow!
‐Wonderful!
Corcoran: When I first met Mitch
on "Shark Tank,"
I thought, "He's the kind of guy
that can make things happen."
And with all of
his perseverance,
we have
a multi‐million‐dollar business,
proving that Christmas is really
about dreams coming true.
Santas: Ho, ho, ho!
Allen: The Santa business
is an evergreen business.
50 years from now,
people will still want Santa
to come to their home,
to their office,
to their retail store,
so I think HireSanta can be
around for a really long time
and really help bring the love
and joy of Christmas
to millions of people
around the world.
Ho, ho, ho!
Santas: Merry Christmas!
♪♪
Narrator: Next up is a way
to bring on the holiday cheer.
♪♪
Herjavec:
[ Chuckles ]
♪♪
Ho, ho, ho!
Corcoran: Wow.
Season's greetings,
Sharks.
My name is
Jason McOmber.
This is Cooper the Elf.
[ Laughs ]
And I know
you all know Santa Claus.
Ho, ho, ho.
[ Laughter ]
I'm the founder and owner
of Beardaments,
and I'm here today
seeking $150,000
in exchange
for 10% of my company.
Now, Sharks, do you recall
the most famous beard‐o of all?
There once
was a jolly man
who gave everyone
Christmas cheer.
But Santa,
he grew bored of wearing
the same outfit each year.
I tried ugly sweaters,
but they all just looked weird.
I know!
...shouted the elf.
Let's put stuff
in your beard!
So he clipped in
bright ornaments
of gold, silver,
red, and green.
Now,
this was holiday spirit
that the North Pole
had never seen.
Beardaments!
...exclaimed Santa.
That's what
they'll be called.
You can clip them
almost anywhere.
Even your chest hair,
if you're bald.
[ Laughter ]
But he didn't stop there,
'cause this Santa had no doubt.
There must be other ways
you could deck a beard out.
So the elves quickly made
beard oil, glitter, and lights.
So anyone
without a Rudolph
could still see
through the night.
The North Pole
was ecstatic!
Santa was looking fly.
Even Mrs. Claus couldn't
keep her hands off this guy.
[ Chuckles ]
Now, Sharks,
who wants to season up
your beard
and step
under the mistletoe...
Make my Christmas wish
come true.
Herjavec: Aww!
And let's watch
your money grow.
Ho, ho, ho!
All right, Sharks,
I know you've all stayed off
the naughty list this year,
so Santa and the elf
are gonna pass out
some samples for you.
‐Cool beans!
‐Wow.
Just when I think
I've seen it all.
‐Right?
‐Yeah.
Wow, thank you,
Cooper the Elf!
I can't wait to put this on.
How about you, Lori?
[ Laughter ]
Herjavec:
Lori, what do you think?
[ Laughing ] Well, Robert,
that's not your best look.
Ho, ho, ho!
We got you a wig, too.
O'Leary: Oh, that's
Very important. thank you.
There you go, Kev.
Beautiful.
Greiner:
You can clip them anywhere.
Cuban: Thank you,
Mr. Cooper the Elf.
I appreciate that.
O'Leary: Well, I think
it's gonna look terrific.
Ho, ho, ho!
McOmber:
You guys look great.
Well, Santa and the Elf have to
go wrap some presents, guys,
so we're gonna send them
on their way.
‐Thank you.
‐Thanks, Santa.
‐Thanks, Cooper the Elf.
‐Bye‐bye.
Greiner: Why did you
come up with this?
So, I started this company
four years ago.
Just a Christmas party,
I decided to hook
some stuff in my beard
after probably
a couple drinks.
Everyone loved it
and thought it was funny.
So, that next year,
we started to sell it.
I actually spent
$1,500 of my own money,
ordered some from China.
I got 1,000 packs,
listed them on Etsy and eBay,
a couple of places online,
and I sold out
of those 1,000 packs
within a couple weeks.
So, our first year,
we did $80,000 in sales.
What?!
$80,000?!
In about two months.
Wow. What'd you do
the second year?
Second year was
$155,000 in sales.
‐What?!
‐Wow.
You got to be kidding.
Herjavec:
What'd you do last year?
$462,000.
What?!
[ Laughs ]
Corcoran: Unbelievable!
And year to date?
We're projecting to do
about $600,000 to $750,000
in sales this year.
And it's all
direct‐to‐customer?
Yes.
This is a UFB ‐‐
un‐frickin'‐believable.
Yeah, it blows me away.
So, the regular beard ornaments
sell for $9.99.
I get them made
for $1.66 per pack.
Unh!
And then
the light‐up ornaments,
this will be our second year
doing the light‐up ornaments.
What do your charge
for those?
$19.99.
They cost me $4.66.
‐What?!
‐$4.26.
Wait, for how many?
10 regular ornaments,
6 lights.
How long does it last?
About two days
of continuous usage.
But you can turn them on
and turn them off.
So you want them to burn out
so they buy again, right?
And how many people
really save a $10 item?
But acquiring
that customer,
it's a subset
of the male population.
Correct.
So, how are you
getting to them?
So, they say 55% of men
have some sort of facial hair,
but where we've been
really lucky is,
we've had a couple videos
go viral.
So, 130 million views...
‐Wow!
...in 2017.
Cost me zero marketing.
And so
that was a huge influx.
O'Leary: But can you get that
every year?
No, but my goal last year
was to maintain the sales,
and I did.
We do a ton
of just e‐mail blasts
out to existing customers,
so I increased sales.
What is your background,
though?
I'm a director of sales
for a telecom distributor.
I'm not an e‐commerce guy.
I'm not a website SEO guy.
I mean, a lot of this
is just me bootstrapping
and shipping
from my basement.
Well, you're killing it.
And I've got some ideas
of where I want to take this.
One thing I think would be great
is sports licensing.
[ Laughing ]
Sports licensing?
Oh, with the Mavs logo
on it?
Sell them at the stadiums
with the Mavericks logo, right?
Or any NFL stadium
and get the licensing
to do little footballs.
I don't know
if that's a great idea.
So, what do you want
the $150,000 for?
I have four things.
It's the licensing.
I want to do other holidays,
so I think Hanukah, Gay Pride,
Independence Day.
Mm.
So there's that.
I don't know about that.
I also want to try
to get into retail
'cause I think
a $10, $20 item,
getting it on the shelves,
I think it'll sell quickly.
And then the fourth would be
just expanding internationally
or trying to broaden.
But, Jason,
you're crushing it.
This is the ultimate UFB.
This is, like ‐‐
This proves
that even the corniest ideas
can make money
if implemented correctly.
Thank you.
I mean, I really think
that you don't need us.
I mean, as much as
I hate to say that,
you're crushing it!
I mean, just put all that money
in your pocket.
This is, like,
a dream for most people.
Thank you.
I just don't see
how it'd be investable for me
in a way
that works for both of us,
so for those reasons,
I'm out.
Understood.
Thank you.
You know, great
that you thought of this.
I get it's kitschy,
it's fun.
I can see people with beards
loving it.
It is so, like,
in‐the‐garage kind of thing,
and look
what you've done with it.
Unbelievable.
And so, amazing.
Kudos to you.
But I agree with Mark 100%.
You don't need a Shark. You have
your own business going.
I think
you're doing great.
And I don't
say this often,
but I don't think
you need a Shark,
and so I'm out.
Okay.
And I appreciate that.
I think the reason I'm here,
it's not about the money for me.
I mean, luckily, like I said,
I do have a job,
but I think having someone
help me take this ‐‐
We're doing half a million
in sales.
I think we could get this
to $3‐ to $5 million in sales.
Jason, I have no aversion
to making money off you.
Awesome.
But why is it worth
$1.5 million?
Right.
So, I think this year ‐‐
'cause I pre‐purchased
the inventory ‐‐
I'm thinking
we're gonna do
around $250,000
to $300,000 in net.
So that's about
five times net profit.
Corcoran: I want to caution you
against one thing.
Yeah.
I invested
in a lot of businesses
that have one product
and a big hit,
and the biggest mistake
the entrepreneurs make
is to try to create
new markets for it.
When you said to me
you're thinking of doing
this holiday or that holiday,
I've seen that attempted
many times.
I've never seen it work.
Maybe come out
with new SKUs each year,
get return customers.
But I think that's what
the business is about.
I don't think there's room
for any partner, so I'm out.
Okay.
Thank you for the feedback.
Herjavec:
Jason, I think you have
a great brand, Beardaments.
This is a part‐time gig
for you.
And there's nothing wrong
with that.
You're making
a boatload of cash.
Right.
But for me to invest,
I want to know you're all‐in.
I wish you the best.
Not for me. I'm out.
Okay.
Thank you.
I appreciate that.
I give you $150,000.
How do I get it back?
By taking part
in those distributions,
and we'll figure out
how to grow the business, right?
And figure out
how to increase sales.
It's so crazy.
I'm looking at it
saying to myself,
"I am the only Shark here
who's made money selling..."
Crazy chicken things.
I Want to Draw a Cat for You.
Excuse me.
Excuse me! Tipsy Elves!
O'Leary:
Okay, I'll give you that.
That was stupid.
It kind of reminds me of,
like, my Potato Parcel deal.
Everybody thought it was a joke.
The guy's making a fortune.
I don't know.
It's tempting, it's tempting.
But I'm hair‐challenged.
That's the problem.
Hey.
[ Laughs ]
‐What?!
‐[ Laughs ]
McOmber:
I understand that, Kevin.
Oh, one of those deals.
♪♪
What does your gut say, Kevin?
What does your gut say?
Greiner:
Go with your gut, Kevin.
Ohh. Okay.
Uh...
You know, it's tough,
because on a crazy deal,
I've made a lot of money
on crazy deals.
I'm gonna pass, Jason.
I'm just ‐‐ It just...
It's...
Womp, womp.
It's great,
but it's frivolous.
That's the problem.
But that's you.
No.
I like money
as much as you do, Kevin.
I like that.
We'll figure out
how to make it work.
Ohh.
$150,000 for 25%.
♪♪
Deal.
Oh, my God!
[ Laughs ]
Don't want to waste any time
with that.
Thank you so much.
You got it, man.
I appreciate it.
All right.
‐Thank you.
‐Congratulations.
‐Thank you so much.
‐Jason, congrats.
McOmber: Kevin is the guy ‐‐
I mean,
from a licensing standpoint
and from the way
that he likes money.
I keep hearing terrible things
about Mr. Wonderful
and how he's the Grinch,
but this time, he really came in
and saved Christmas.
That's your kind of deal.
Kevin, you have a heart.
It's a Christmas miracle!
♪♪
Narrator: Next up is
an affordable solution
for a favorite winter sport.
♪♪
Hi. My name is Forrest Shinners,
and I'm from Stowe, Vermont.
I'm an avid skier
and snowboarder.
These sports are awesome,
but they can also be expensive.
Sure, you can rent the skis
or boards,
but what about the apparel?
A jacket, pants, goggles,
gloves, boots ‐‐ all that.
We call that a kit.
And if you have to buy all
the gear to be fully kitted out,
the cost can really add up.
And what if you only go
once in a while?
Essentially,
it's like burning money.
No!
[ Laughs ]
Don't worry, Mr. Wonderful.
I would never actually burn
real money.
Showbiz.
Wow.
[ Laughter ]
So, let's say you have to buy
an outfit for yourself.
Or your kids.
They outgrow their clothes
every year.
Or what if you have to kit out
your entire family?
It can turn into
a real garbage fire.
Don't try this at home, kids.
‐Whoa!
‐Ooh!
That's why
I created Kit Lender.
Kit Lender is an online outdoor
gear and apparel rental company.
We make it easier,
less expensive,
and more convenient
for people to get away
and enjoy the outdoors.
Here's how it works.
Kit Lender allows you to rent
everything you need
for outdoor sports,
from jackets and pants
to goggles and gloves,
all for as little
as just $30 a day.
Our 24/7 customer service
is always there for you.
And we ship free to and from
your resort or vacation rental.
We carry
toddler through 3XL sizes
for men and women
and constantly update
our offerings
with the newest styles.
So, no more storing gear
during the off‐season,
worrying if everything
is packed,
or agonizing over the cost
and hassle
of schlepping gear everywhere.
Kit Lender's got you covered.
So now you can finally
stop burning money and time,
with Kit Lender.
And with that, I guess it's time
to discuss the money.
I'm seeking $200,000
for 7% equity.
Ooh.
Does anyone have a...
burning question?
[ Laughter ]
‐Whoo!
‐Again.
How did you
come up with the idea?
So, I grew up in Stowe, Vermont.
My parents have a ski shop.
They've had it for 45 years.
So, I literally have grown up
in the ski industry.
After college,
moved to New York City,
did the standard
working in finance.
All my friends,
like most New Yorkers,
didn't have the ski clothing
or didn't want to carry it
with them,
so when they'd come up
to my house in Vermont,
I'd say, "Don't worry.
You can just borrow stuff
from our closets."
Well, a couple friends said,
"Wow. This is a great service.
How much do we owe you
for it?"
So, you know, of course,
I had that "Aha" moment.
Looked online ‐‐
there was nobody doing it.
So hustled together
some money,
bought some inventory,
bootstrapped a website.
How long ago
was this?
This would've been
in 2014.
We launched officially
in 2015.
And then first year,
selling out, you know,
we only had
limited inventory.
I was flying up to Stowe,
shipping stuff out,
shipping out of my apartment.
My mom would help me
clean stuff.
So, 2015 was great.
That's when
I pretty much realized
that I had a, um...
a pretty unhealthy relationship
with alcohol,
[ Voice breaking ]
and, um...
So...
So I quit drinking
and focused on this business,
as well as working
a full‐time day job,
and that's what I've been doing
for the past four years.
Um...
And then,
just this last spring,
I actually quit my day job
and started working
on Kit Lender full time.
Good for you.
What are your sales?
Last year, we did
about $755,000 in sales.
Wow.
What cash did you make
on the $750,000?
$106,000 in EBITDA.
Forrest,
how does it work?
Can you walk me through?
I love that yellow outfit
on mini Robert.
[ Laughs ]
So, I go to ‐‐
I didn't give you a wig.
Sorry.
[ Laughter ]
Walk me
through the process.
Sure.
So, go online,
our outfits are set up
for kits.
So you'd pick a kit.
It's usually based
on the jacket.
You'd check out.
We'd then hold that order
until you wanted to ski.
So, you'd pick
your first ski day.
How long does it take you
to ship it to me?
It depends on
when you're going.
So, we ask for four days before,
minimum, before your ski trip.
So, you send it to me.
I use it for four days.
Yep.
Do I just put it back
in one of your boxes,
just throw it all
in there?
They come in garment bags,
so, actually, it's easy.
You know,
you'd have Robert's kit
and little Robert's kit,
and, you know,
you'd put them all back
in your garment bags,
tape it back up.
It has
the pre‐paid FedEx label.
And it's how much per kit?
So, the kids' kits
are $18 up to $22.
Per day?
Per day.
And adults?
Adults start at about $30,
and they go up to $44.
So if I'm on a three‐day
weekend, it's 120 bucks.
I'm fully outfitted,
and I feel like I'm fashionable.
And you look awesome.
I think it's great value.
Yeah.
On the back end,
how do the logistics work?
Are you buying a whole wack
of inventory?
Yeah.
So, we're buying
the inventory.
Our hope is to get
three seasons out of it.
So, how much inventory would you
have right now, dollar value?
So, about $550
in wholesale value.
I'm not a skier.
Okay.
So, this isn't really
up my alley.
Got it.
I do think it is smart.
Thank you.
But I also think it's
an inventory nightmare a bit.
It's just not
really my cup of tea,
so I'm sorry ‐‐
I'm out.
Thank you.
Forrest, you know,
like most companies,
there's a balance between
trying to raise enough money
and not raise too much,
right?
In your particular case, you've
gotten some good traction,
but in order
for this to work,
it's gonna cost you
a lot more.
So, number one, first,
congratulations
on your sobriety.
Thank you.
Four years is
a hell of an accomplishment.
Thank you.
Congrats.
But it's really not a fit for me
right now.
So for those reasons,
I'm out.
Thank you, Mark.
You're welcome.
Corcoran: I've had five kids
that I've taught to ski,
and I can tell you, the worst
part about having family
is outfitting those damn kids
every year with new stuff.
I get cheaper as I go
because it's so expensive.
But to Mark's point,
I think the amount of money
that it's going to take
to do this right,
all the things to make it
a big, forceful business
is gonna cost you
so much money.
But all the while,
I'm thinking to myself
it's mis‐marketed.
The rich people
that ski all the time
spend money on ski clothes,
and they spend a lot on it.
It's the kids
that are the problem.
I keep thinking you should
market it toward the children.
Perhaps bad advice,
but that's my own 2 cents on it.
So for those reasons,
I'm out.
Forrest, your industry is unique
in this respect.
Very few recreational markets
have two players
that know where
80% of the customers are.
These two players have spent
billions of dollars
acquiring pretty well
every mountain
in America and Canada.
They own them all.
They have all the customers.
You have a great idea.
Either you go there
and cut a deal
for customer acquisition
or someone else will
after they see
how good this idea is.
'Cause the incremental rental
is a great idea.
But in this market,
you got to think big,
'cause there's no moat
around this business.
Someone else is gonna think big.
It should be you.
I'm sorry, Forrest.
I'm out.
All right.
It's a brilliant,
brilliant idea.
I mean,
I thought you'd be in.
But there's gonna be two types
of companies in this business ‐‐
the quick and the dead.
Another one of my lines
he stole.
And for you to be
really quick,
you're gonna need
a lot of money,
and more importantly,
you have to get the customer
at the point
they book the ski outing.
So, we'll get ‐
we'll work on ‐‐
But you got to have
those affiliate programs.
And, I mean,
the table's set to me.
I mean, that's why
I'm reaching out to you guys.
I mean, I'd love to have you
as a partner.
I also have an Italian
motorcycle that I ride.
[ Laughter ]
We could hang out.
We can go skiing.
♪ Kumbaya ♪
I honestly think
it's a great idea.
Come on, Robert.
You would be
an awesome partner.
I mean, I...
You will not find anybody
that's gonna work harder
on this thing.
I have built it so hard
to this point,
and I think I'm ready
to take it to the next level.
That's why I did quit,
'cause I was like ‐‐
I saw competitors come in.
I knew we had something.
You know,
I don't sleep.
I eat, breathe, I'm gonna be
fulfilling packages.
You're a great guy.
I just ‐‐
It doesn't feel right to me.
I think you got to go
even faster.
I'm sorry. I'm out.
Thank you.
Congrats, Forrest.
Good luck with everything.
Thank you very much.
Good luck.
Thank you.
♪♪
Just 'cause I didn't
get a deal today
doesn't mean that Kit Lender
is gonna stop growing.
We're gonna continue to grow,
we're gonna continue
to get people outdoors,
and we're gonna be the name
in outdoor gear rental.
♪♪
Narrator:
Next into the Tank is a way
to make a holiday chore easier.
♪♪
Hi, Sharks.
My name is Bryan Perla.
I'm 21 years old, from
West Boylston, Massachusetts.
I am the owner and inventor
of Little Elf gift‐wrap cutter.
Today, I'm seeking $150,000
in exchange
for 15% stake in my company.
Sharks, we all know
the holiday season is stressful.
Do we really need one more thing
to test our patience?
Like cutting wrapping paper
with scissors.
[ Laughs ]
♪♪
Ugh!
Everyone hates
cutting wrapping paper
because it always comes out
ripped, jagged, or crooked.
All of this paper
has been left useless
for anything
but the recycling bin.
That's why I have revolutionized
the way people cut gift wrap,
with the Little Elf ‐‐
the easy, lightweight,
and fast gift‐wrap cutter.
In just a few seconds,
you can cut straight
and feel great.
Just measure the paper
to your desired length,
slide the Little Elf back
so the sheet of paper drops
into the blade‐embedded slot,
and then with ease,
push the Little Elf forward.
‐Wow!
‐That's pretty good.
Getting a smooth, clean,
and extremely satisfying cut
every single time.
So, Sharks,
I know you all could use
a little helper
this holiday season.
So, who's ready to join me
getting wrapped up...
Me! I hate cutting paper.
...in a cutting‐edge investment
with the Little Elf?
I want to try it.
I actually want
to try, too.
You guys can come on up
and try it.
So, first,
what you're gonna do,
you can just grab
this sheet of paper.
Uh‐huh.
Slide this Little Elf back...
...so it drops into
that blade‐embedded slot.
Oh, I see.
And then just move it forward
with ease.
Yeah!
Barbara, how is it?
Hard to aim,
easy to do once you got it.
Yep. And then
just slide it forward.
Wow.
That's pretty ingenious.
Lori, was it easy?
It really was.
And it doesn't matter
how big or how small
the piece of paper is,
right?
But what if I only want
half the sheet?
So, I can show you that
right now.
So, it's great for trimming,
as well.
You're gonna insert it
into the blade slot, like this,
with the Little Elf
upside‐down,
and then you can trim the paper
just like that.
It's just that easy.
How much does it cost?
So, on Amazon, we're selling
a two‐pack for $13.99,
and on our website,
we're selling anywhere
from $5.99 to $7.49,
depending on the quantity.
How'd you come up
with this?
I've always had
just the knack for, like,
thinking of ideas,
coming up with solutions.
But that was confusing
to my teachers
as, like,
an elementary school student
because I really struggled
with reading, writing,
and comprehension.
Finally, in second grade,
I was diagnosed
with pretty severe dyslexia.
Yes!
Yep.
Me too.
So, for the rest
of my elementary school,
I struggled
with, you know,
reading
three, four grades behind.
Finally, in fifth grade,
I was transferred to a school
specifically
for dyslexic students.
Throughout high school,
I really embraced that.
I developed and designed
what is today
the Little Elf gift‐wrap cutter.
And how old were you
at the time?
I was a senior
in high school.
What?!
Yep.
[ Clapping ]
[ Laughs ] Really?
Yeah, Bryan!
Good job.
And right now,
I am actually a junior
at Stanford University
up in Palo Alto.
Wow!
Wow. You got over
your dyslexia.
What are you studying
at Stanford?
Product design. So,
it's the perfect match for me.
Perfect fit.
What are your sales
this year, and how much
money are you gonna make?
To date, we've done
$250,000 in sales.
Wow.
You're doing everything alone,
and you own it 100%?
I am running
the whole business myself.
I do have
a licensing agreement
with the world's
largest gift‐wrap company.
So, my deal is,
for the next two to four years,
I get 10% to 13%
of retail sales only.
But I can sell online,
I can sell on QVC,
HSN, online shopping...
Have you been
on QVC, HSN?
We have not.
What is your cost
to make it?
$2.09.
Cuban:
So, it costs you $2.09.
What's your average
sales price?
$15.
So, you're selling
multiple units, typically.
Yep.
Bryan, you're killing it.
Your margins are, like, 80%.
Mm‐hmm.
What else do you need?
Help with advertising.
You know, I haven't spent
a dime on advertising.
That's just to drive
your online sales?
Just to drive online sales.
Get on TV shopping
would be huge.
Someone sees it in action,
they're gonna fall in love
with it immediately.
Listen,
I think I've heard enough.
I'm gonna
make you an offer.
I feel I'd be a great partner
for you because this is visual.
And I think I could blow this up
on QVC and also elsewhere.
But I think you need help.
So, it would be
$150,000 for 30%.
Ohh.
So that we can be ‐‐
Good thing
I'm here, Bryan.
Well, so that
we can be partners.
As a fellow dyslexic,
I'm gonna make you
an offer, too.
We're in the same club.
I'm not as greedy.
I, too, will bring you in
under my vendor co at QVC
and my team.
I will personally sell it
on my show.
[ Chuckles ]
We'll sell a ton of it.
Whoa!
A little competition.
Yeah,
we have competition.
But I'm gonna
structure it differently.
I'm gonna give you
$150,000.
I'm gonna apply a royalty
of $1 a unit you can afford
until I get back $450,000.
Then that goes away forever.
I want 10% of the company.
And I will blow it up huge
on Amazon and on your website.
Huge. It'll be insane
what happens.
You have two offers.
What do you want to do?
I mean, I ‐‐
I thank you both.
I think it would be
foolish of me not to
listen to everyone else.
I have a question.
Yeah.
Repeat back to me
what Kevin offered you.
So, he offered me $150,000
for 10% with a...
$1 royalty.
...$1 royalty
until he gets back $450,000.
So, I'll do his deal,
but I'll go 75 cents
in royalty.
I'll drop it to 50 cents.
I'll drop it to 45 cents.
I'm helping you out here
a lot, I'd say.
I'll drop it to 40.
I'll drop it to 35.
That's gonna take 2...
...thousand years.
No, no, no.
[ Laughter ]
So, I would rather,
from my point of view,
have a partner
with just equity.
No royalty at all?
Yeah.
I have not taken any money
out of this myself.
I'm good with that.
So, my offer was
$150,000 for 30%.
Okay.
Do you want to counter?
I will offer $150,000
for 25%.
I can sell hundreds of thousands
of these in minutes in my show.
So can I.
I mean,
no offense to Kevin,
but my show
is way more popular.
No, that's not true
at all.
Yes, it is very true.
Oh, my God! It's so true!
That's not true.
No, that's not true.
But anyway,
I'll give you an offer ‐‐
$150,000, 20%.
I hope you take it.
So, my last offer
was at 25%,
and you've dropped to 20%,
no royalty, straight equity.
Yes.
That's the deal?
What are you going to do?
♪♪
Narrator:
All Sharks are still in.
Kevin and Lori
are in a bidding war
over the gift‐wrap cutting tool
Little Elf.
My last offer was at 25%,
and you've dropped to 20%,
no royalty, straight equity.
Yes.
That's the deal?
Hey, Bryan, you are
one impressive guy.
I got to tell you,
you are the spirit
of what makes
this country great.
You didn't make excuses.
You overcame incredible odds.
I admire that.
It's not my space.
Both of these guys
are great.
I'm out.
I really appreciate your time.
Thank you. That's very kind.
Bryan, I'm gonna
clear the floor,
but I really want you
to encourage you.
I think you're fine
on your own.
I can't even imagine
what you'd need a Shark in.
I'm out.
Okay.
♪♪
Cuban:
So, Bryan, I'm trying to get
a feel of where you want to go,
because one side says,
you know what?
You can make a lot of money
with the licensing play,
plus doing it
from your website,
plus just adding some SEO
for Amazon.
Yeah.
Right?
I know what Lori can do.
She can do great things.
But what's important here
is your vision
and how you want
to see it blow up.
I mean, I've sold over 1,000
successful products...
But that's not
what he's saying.
on QVC alone.
Bryan, don't you think
every Shark does that
with all of
their entrepreneurs?
We've been doing this
for 10 years.
No. You don't.
Lori's the only one that makes
money with their entrepreneurs.
Not with
my success rate, Kevin.
We all do it.
I sell all my deals on QVC,
including Lovepop Cards,
which has been
an unmitigated hit.
Yes.
And that's because of the
gifting seasons around holiday,
we kill it.
Bryan, what is it
that you want in a partner?
Yeah,
I want to answer that.
What is it that you want
for yourself? What's missing?
You want a dyslexic.
[ Laughter ]
Here I am, baby.
The retail license opportunity
is great.
You have that in your pocket,
though, right?
Yeah.
So, while the retail licenser
is, you know,
really growing
that business,
I just need to make sure
that I'm doing my due diligence,
and making sure
that it's a cool item
that someone can buy
online.
And you have two good offers.
I think Lori's at 20%.
Do you want to be
on TV, though?
I'm curious.
Like, would you want to be ‐‐
My entrepreneurs
come on with me in my show.
Yeah.
You know,
it's very much a 50/50.
You could come on my show
and get some wine.
So, Bryan,
if that's the goal, right?
If you like that idea
of being on QVC and doing that,
it's not in my wheelhouse.
For those reasons,
I'm out.
You're out. okay.
O'Leary: Let's just
summarize the offers.
I've offered you the $150,000,
no royalty, for 25%.
Lori's at $150,000
for 20%.
The extra 5 is
for the Mr. Wonderful part.
'Cause there's only one
Mr. Wonderful.
I'm not discounting
myself.
Is there any way
you would work together?
No.
No?
That is not
the answer.
O'Leary:
We don't need to.
But you know in your heart
the right way to go.
♪♪
Kevin, we're dyslexic.
We have that bond.
But Lori is
the best option for this,
and I'd like to make
a deal with you.
Huge mistake.
Whoo!
‐Yes!
‐I accept your deal.
Seriously,
we will blow this up.
I will not let you down.
Thank you.
Absolutely huge mistake.
This product has "Lori"
written all over it.
Thank you,
all of you.
Congratulations, Bryan.
It's done.
Come on, Kevin.
I'm so sorry
you made that mistake.
Herjavec: [ Laughs ]
Great job, Bryan!
Perla:
Lori's the perfect partner
for Little Elf
because, you know,
everyone watching QVC
is the perfect
target audience for this,
and I'm on there with her,
demoing it.
You know, like she said,
she could sell
hundreds of thousands
within minutes.
♪♪